welcome back everyone to round five of
the dubai rapid tournament if you've
been keeping up with the series you'll
know i'm four out of four at this point
and in round five i'm playing
grandmaster your decision from moldova
his rapid rating is 2632
which puts him among the top players in
the world and he was a top seed in
tournament before this game i had a
little time to prepare
and i knew he plays
e4 on move one
and i was debating whether to go into a
stafford gambit
but i did have a chance to look up his
online games and i saw against petrov he
actually avoids the stafford entirely by
playing d4 on move three
and i didn't want to go into this
especially in a rapid game where
he'd probably know more than me
so i decided to stick with my serious
tournament repertoire
which is a sicilian defense and more
specifically i usually like to go for
the taiman of sicilian which happens
after knight f3 e6 d4 takes takes
knight c6 knight c3 and queen c7
this has been my kind of main choice for
black
over the many years of playing in
serious tournaments
however my opponent decided to avoid the
open sicilian and play the move g3 in
this position this is a so-called
anti-sicilian it has become a bit more
trendy recently
i believe wesley so recommends this in
one of his chestable courses
and the idea is very simple to just
encounter the bishop castle
and then later sometimes light goes for
c3 d4 sometimes plays a more closed
position with d3 more kind of king's
indian style attack
and
thankfully i had some idea what to do
here i have studied this line over the
years
and i went for kind of my main opening
prep is knight c6 bishop g2
five six
queen e2
and here i played um a somewhat
counter-intuitive looking move
but it is justified for the position
here white wants to play e5 and disturb
my knight on f6
and
the way to prevent that is actually by
playing e5 myself
and even though it looks a bit strange
to have played e6 on move two and then
e5 on move five it makes sense in this
position because it fixes white's pawn
on e4 which blocks the bishop
limits the queen
sometimes in chess it's okay losing a
little bit of time if
you're disturbing the opponent from
their plans
um so here my opponent went ahead
castles play bishop b7 c3 castling
knight a3
here comes a moment where i forgot my
specific preparation and i should have
known better to play the move rook e8
this is by far the most flexible move
some x-ray vision against the queen
also there's cases where i want to play
bishop f8 and defend the pawn on e5 with
the rook and this would have been nice
because it keeps the option open of
playing d5
if uh if it works out in the position
for example if i plays knight c2
i can get away with playing d5 here and
after takes take with queen defend the
pawn have a nice space advantage
and there's really no concern with
discoveries because white doesn't have a
great way to
move the knight and target my queen
in the game i ended up playing pawn d6
which of course is still very normal
looking but it just limited my options
because i'm committing myself to playing
the structure
and not giving myself the immediate
option of going for d5 however the game
continues from here opponent plays
knight c2
i play rook e8
d3
and now b5
so we're kind of transitioning from the
opening into the middle game
and so far we've both kind of just
stayed within our territory
playing just very solid chess white has
his own very solid hard to break setup
and
with b5 i'm trying to make some progress
on the queen side
i did have the plan of someday playing
b4
and try and open up some lines and
create some weaknesses
my opponent continued to play solidly
played bishop d2
play rook b8
a3
and now a5
and i was feeling pretty good at this
point given that most of the focus has
been on the queen side
and generally in these positions white
wants to go for the eventual king side
attack with some like knight e3 move the
knight play f4 knight f5 ideas
and
it seems like so far white's a little
bit slow to unleash those plans
playing moves like a3 and bishop d2 and
just giving me time to expand and gain
space
however white still kind of just
remained solid he went ahead played
knight e3
and here i go for the break pawn b4 very
well supported by both pawns the knight
and the rook
i do want to open some files however
this perhaps favored white because
rather than the b file opening
white took on b4 and played c4
closing down the b file
and the c file and keeping the a file
open
and now it's white who has control of
this file
so this may have been some
slight improvement for white
at the same time kind of a big shift has
taken place in the center
white is clamping down on the d5 square
but has given me full control of the d4
square and this is going to become
relevant in just a few more moves
but first i complete development bishop
e6
h3 queen d7
hitting the pawn
king h2 very standard
and in this position i made my first
slight kind of dubious move of the game
um i played my move rather quickly
thinking that i was just playing a
natural improving move that being bishop
to f8
in hindsight this is a mistake and we're
going to see why what i should have done
is just challenge the a file should have
played rook a8
with idea that
i want to bring my queen to b7
take on a1 and bring the other rotate
and try and gain control over the file
for example if white plays knight d5
i can take take
queen b7 with idea of playing rook 8 and
controlling the file meanwhile
everything on the king's side is
relatively under control
and this would have been approximately
equal
now if we compare this to what happened
in the game
when i play bishop f8 this allows white
to hop in right away with knight d5
my opponent played this
relatively quickly we do have the time
stamps here so we can see
how much time was spent on each move
and i'm pretty sure they're accurate
because it was broadcast with the gtt
board and a dgt clock so knight d5 is
very powerful here
because
it threatens to take my knights on f6
and i can't take on d5 with my knight
because then i get forked
and i really don't want to take on d5
with the bishop
because then white takes back and i can
see the bishop hair however this was
what i ended up doing in the game i
didn't see a great alternative for me
i did check this with the engine
afterwards
and stockfish recommends just moving my
bishop back to e7
so essentially losing to tempe
which during the game i i didn't want to
admit
my mistake of moving the bishop to f8
so i did go ahead i took
and here the position transforms white
takes on d5
and i go for knight to a7
now some of you might be wondering why i
didn't play knight d4
but i thought this would have given
white very easy play white would be
happy to trade
i'd be left with a very bad bishop on f8
my pawns fixed on dark squares and white
would be
expanding on the king's side
and i felt like if we got to this
position i would just kind of get
smooshed
so
i was more content with leaving the
knight
on the board
and then remaneuvering it to b5
so here bishop e3 was played play knight
b5
and now very nice maneuver from white
knight d2 this is multi-purpose
it does prepare f4 which is white's main
way of making progress in the position
on top of that white's planning to
maneuver the knight to c4 pressuring e5
and it's very very hard to remove the
knight once it lands on c4
so here i finally
challenged a file with rook 8
knight c4s played queen b7
we trade on 8
and
here white plays f4
so at this point i feel like i'm getting
outplayed position is beginning to look
very unpleasant this bishop is very
passive white's expanding with a clear
plan
even though i'm now controlling a file
it's really hard to make progress on the
queen side
this knight really just holds everything
together pressures my center
so i played the move 97
after about a minute think
and here we can see i'm already
approaching the three minute mark my
opponent has a decent amount of time
you play this next move quite quickly
queen f2 queen f2 is actually a really
nice move from white because it creates
a battery on that file
f7 is now becoming a more clear target
and it also creates a battery against c5
so there's potential later to take
and then if i take back with pawn c5
could be a weakness
so here i spent even more time and
eventually decided to play pawn takes
pawn not a move i really wanted to play
but
it was hard to find anything much better
i felt a bit stuck
and the benefit of taking with a pawn is
that if white takes back with the queen
i can play the move f6 and secure
control over the e5 square have the idea
of 95 and i was hoping to get a
situation like this where at least i can
try and hold my ground and be somewhat
solid but my opponent made the right
decision took back with the pawn
now even though this does block that
file
it uh very clearly prepares the vengeful
e5 break it also opens up the g3 square
for the queen
here i went ahead and played knight b6
this was one of the ideas with knight d7
is to trade off white's very well placed
knight and here my opponent wastes no
time with the move pawn e5
very strong move yet again
trying to unleash this diagonal so in
the event that i take
white has a soul-crushing move pawn d6
skewering
and uh yeah black's losing a lot of
material here
so i can't really take the pawn e5 and i
definitely don't want to take the knight
on c4 this will only strengthen white's
already immaculate center
so instead i tried to hold my ground
with a move rook t8
reinforcing the pawn
and my opponent plays e6 yet another
very strong move just continually
gaining space
in the center
i don't want to take this pawn and allow
de6 with the bishop opening up my queen
would be tied down to the knights this
would be highly highly unpleasant
so with just 31 seconds left
i had to rely on some intuition
and i play the move which looks really
strange at first
but i think it was the best practical
decision
is to play pawn f5
now uh the first thing i should note
white count on passant that's not legal
it's not how ambison works
if you're confused google on basant
and with f5 i just try and close down
the position
even though these pawns
are very strong
it's hard for them to make more progress
and both bishops for white are a bit
restricted in the position
light squared bishop being restricted by
the center pawns
and this bishop being restricted by my
pawns on the dark squares
so yeah even though the position looks
grim
and i'm very very low on time
just surviving on the the five second
increment
i did have a little bit of hope from
here
my opponent here played knight to a5
which is a very natural kind of
positional improvement the knight is
about to find an even stronger square on
c6 now i do want to back up because it
turns out white had a
absolutely amazing tactic here
instead of knight a5
white had the move bishop takes c5 the
point is white sacrifices a whole piece
with intention of now making progress
with the pawns
and the fact that the queen's attacked
queen is tied down to the knight e7 is
coming
this is uh
just going completely downhill for black
thankfully my opponent can go for this
went for knight a5
and i am staying alive i move my queen
over
knight c6
rook eight and here i was expecting my
opponent to just win a clean pawn turns
out there is a pretty simple tactic here
for whites because my c5 pawn is pinned
by the queen bishop battery
white does have the option of taking on
b4
but instead my opponent went for queen
c2
i went for g6 defending f5
white improves with rookie 1
i improved with bishop to g7
and i'm beginning to have more hope
the pieces that i do have they're
finding some harmony especially with the
queen side
some idea of playing rook a2 and
targeting the b-pawn but
as we're going to see it's still a very
difficult position to play with very
little time my opponent moves the queen
back to f2
and here i really wanted to play rook to
a2 and just start targeting the b-pawn
get some initiative of my own
unfortunately this doesn't quite work
due to e7 and the fact that the rook has
some x-ray vision to support the pawn
on its journey to becoming a queen
uh this would uh not turn out well for
me i would have no time to take
because white's just queening
so instead i played
what looks to be a passive move but i
thought the
position calls for this move is knight
c8
aiming to get the knight to a black
hating square on e7
and here is where the video is going to
take a slightly different turn
unbeknownst to me
at this moment in the game
one of my good friends irene sukundar
had finished her game and she had her
gopro and started recording
and uh this is where i'm gonna do some
pseudo live commentary
so i've never done this before hopefully
i can sync up the moves with the
commentary and everything will go
smoothly so let's see how the game
unfolds from here opponent was taking
his time uh of course he saw my idea of
playing 97
and
i had to be ultra ultra focused here
just trying to anticipate his next move
and he went ahead and played d4 a very
nice move for the position
trying to open up lines
i didn't have much time i took on d4 now
i was expecting him to take back
with one of these pieces
but he actually surprised me um maybe he
didn't want to allow like if knight
takes i can take and play knight d7
if bishop takes i can take take and play
queen c5 so he dropped back to d2
and i was very quick here to play 97
finally achieving the blockade of the
the monster e pawn
and here he takes a pawn on b4
so uh if we count material i am down
upon
trying to figure out what to do i take
on c6
he takes back
and i very quickly play d5
trying to exploit the f4 pawn which is
only defended by the queen
but he's
quick to play e7
now the pawn is just one square away
from queening
and i took on c6
which looks like it does everything it
covers e8 it defends d5
the problem with this move
is a queen is overworked sometimes when
a piece is doing too many jobs
it can very easily get punished
as we're going to see
and here my opponent
is about to uncork a really nice
nice and simple
tactical combination
and i saw it coming but okay there's
nothing i can do i can just kind of sit
and try and
react in the best way possible
opponent makes a queen he has this queen
in hand already ready i take
now he plays bishop d5 deflecting my
queen i take back
he goes up the exchange play king f7
only move
um as we can see i gained a little bit
of time on the clock but my king is uh
very exposed the rook is in my face here
i was expecting rookie 7 but it turns
out white has another
candidate move that
he was very wise to
take a moment here
and consider his options because
sometimes it's not always necessary to
deliver the first check that comes to
mind
and yeah he goes ahead plays queen to e2
uh threatening maiden one
i have very very few options here should
know my queen is tied down to my knight
so
like to defend with my queen but i
choose to defend with a bishop
with bishop to f6
and shortly after i played this move you
can't really see it in my expression
but i realize white has a very simple
winning combination
now he began to take his time so i was
actually a bit hopeful
that he wouldn't find the winning
combination here
i will say that the first move is to
start with rook f8
and then king g7
and then it'll be white to move and win
so he had one minute and 13 seconds to
start thinking from this position
but he ran this clock down to less than
a minute finally plays rook f8 and then
very quickly plays queen e8 should note
rook f6 and queen e7
uh could have led to mate and here i
didn't have much time to react
uh white's going for mating attack
i went ahead and played queen f3
uh trying to get counter play i was
dreaming of perpetual check
at this point we're both very low on
time
he's falling below 30 seconds probably
and uh it turns out it's white to move
and force mates
you can kind of see it in his expression
that he he spots something
um i think he took a little bit of extra
time just to double check
that everything's working for white
but he goes ahead plays rook f7
king h6 queen f8 king h5
and rook h7 took me a moment to know
this but this is check and mate
and uh yeah that was round five
somewhat dramatic ending
i felt like i got
completely outplayed for most of this
game
but it does turn out i had a miracle
save
just before the very end
i want to back up just a few moves
and i know a lot of those moves unfolded
very quickly so i do want to point out
queenie yates
turned out to be
a serious serious blunder what white
should have done as i very quickly
mentioned
is take on f6
king takes f6 just gets made in one to
queen e7 i really thought he was gonna
see it given how long he he spent uh
before playing rook f8
but sometimes in a position like this
when you have
a few good looking options it's hard to
pinpoint which one is the most accurate
and to be fair queen e8 does look
winning just because my king is uh is
about to get mated it did happen in the
game
but it turns out in this position
it's black to move
and survive there's only one move
that basically leads to equality
i will admit that i only discovered this
with engine after the game
and the resource for black is somewhat
engine like but the move to save
everything
is knight to c7
now what this does is it keeps f7 and g8
covered by the queen so there's none
none of this uh checkmate shenanigans
for white meanwhile the queen is
attacked by my knight
and the position gets a little bit
awkward for white
just to show one really nice example
line
if white keeps the battery on eighth
rank with queen c8
there's a really cool move bishop to e5
and this would have been like super
human i think if i played this move
maybe i would get accused of cheating
but the point being i defend the knight
i attack the pawn
and if pawn dig's bishop
queen takes e5 leads to a draw because
the king is completely naked my queen
will have all the fun delivering
perpetual check
so it was a bit unfortunate that i
missed knight c7 but overall i was still
pleased with my play didn't make too
many super obvious mistakes this game
and my opponent played really strongly
to
outplay me
and take home the win
so after this game i stood at four out
of five in the standings this was a nine
round tournament so there's still lots
of room to fight back
and compete for the prizes and the money
so stay tuned for my round six recap
video as always if you have any
questions leave them in the comments
below
and i look forward to seeing you in the
next video